how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome to this week's episode of Theory
Thursday this week we have some really
great theories short and sweet but they
make you think especially with
everything that is coming up in the MCU
with spider-man far from home and the
new characters and a big congratulations
to last week's winner Alfred at Norman
barbacena his theory was last week's
theory number five about Namor being the
cause of the underground earthquake that
was mentioned in Avengers endgame
Congrats Alfred you are now eligible to
compete for the monthly prize so let's
dive on in with some awesome theories
right off the bat theory number one the
first theory comes from Lorenzo Miguel
and Lorenzo's theory is that in
spider-man far from home there are
actually two Mysterio's one good one and
one bad one one from our universe and
one from the alternate universe Lorenzo
also thinks that the good Mysterio could
have already been killed or will be
killed by the evil Mysterio and
spider-man far from home this actually
makes a lot of sense because they are
introducing the multiverse in spider-man
far from home so there would be two
Mysterio's one from our universe one
from the other universe and Mysterio is
no doubt a villain he pretends to be
good but is in fact a villain but
perhaps the Mysterio that we are seen in
the trailers is actually good but maybe
later on in the movie we see the evil
Mysterio come out definitely something
that could happen especially with the
multiverse being introduced
okay that's theory number one on to
theory number two theory number two
comes from Ghaith of Anor and I'm really
sorry if I butchered your name there but
gates theory is that Professor Hulk
actually sees Natasha after snapping
just like Thanos saw Gamora
right after he snapped in Avengers
infinity war case says that when
Professor Hulk's eyes rolled back and he
passes out holding caps hand you can
clearly see his mouth moving as if he's
talking to somebody maybe he's talking
to Natasha and holding her hand this
actually makes sense in a couple of
different ways because they a nose did
see Gamora after he snapped Gamora was
the person that Thanos cared about the
most and Natasha was probably the person
that Bruce Banner cared about the most
and Gamora was the sole sacrifice to
obtain the soul stone just like Natasha
was the sole sacrifice to obtain the
soul stone as
and if Thanos saw Gamora after he
snapped why wouldn't Bruce see Natasha
after he snapped it makes sense
so that's Theory number two on to theory
number three theory number three comes
from Timmy and his theory is that
Quicksilver is actually still alive to
me says that an age of Ultron a big deal
was made about two thinks hawkeye's
injury and the cradle vision came from
Clint's injury was healed using an
advanced skin grafting procedure and the
cradle gave life to vision we never saw
a burial scene for Pedro and his body
was taken aboard the Helicarrier in one
of those so-called lifeboats what a fury
did for Patriot he did for Coulson and
agents of shield healing Pedro's wounds
using the grafting then putting him in
the cradle to revive him since his
injuries were so severe it would take
time to heal properly which would
explain why he hasn't been around also
tying this into the scene at the end of
Avengers in game with Wanda and Clint
where Clint says he wishes that he could
let Natasha know that they won and Wanda
says I'm sure she knows I'm sure they
both do Timmy thinks Wanda is talking
about Natasha and of course vision but
shouldn't she be more reflecting on her
brother since an in-game they could have
gone back to save him not to mention we
never really saw her mourn after age of
Ultron is this perhaps because he is
alive well this is something that they
did do with Agent Coulson he died in the
first Avengers film and then popped up
in agents of shield using the exact
procedure that Timmy described and it
does make you think if they could do
that for Agent Coulson who had a severe
wound right through the middle of his
chest why couldn't they do that for
Pedro and not to mention he was spotted
on the set of Avengers endgame now he
wasn't in the movie but perhaps he's
still associated with Marvel I believe
he even had more movies left on his
contract so perhaps he's somebody who
could show up in phase 4 okay that's
theory number three on to number four
theory number four comes from Brennan
O'Donnell who also has a Mysterio theory
Brennan does not think that Mysterio is
from another dimension or that this
movie will introduce the multiverse but
that's just what Mysterio wants
everybody to believe
Brennan believes that Quentin Beck was
trained by the ancient one in the
mystical arts before dr. strange and
defected just like Basilius did his
powers seem very similar in style to dr.
Strange's Beck is notable in the comics
for pretending to be good but being evil
all along and I
that when the decimation happened he
started to work on his tech and magic to
create the Mysterio persona and claimed
that he was from another dimension with
careful plotting and his mastery of the
mystic arts he could create such a
convincing lie that even Nick Fury would
believe him the moment the world lost
Iron Man Captain America Thor and
Captain Marvel being gone was the
perfect time to unleash his plan and
introduce the world to the elementals
which are probably a little more than
illusions and to trick the world into
believing he is the hero they need at
the moment
spider-man will ultimately of course
figure out that he is in fact evil and
will ultimately defeat him brennon makes
a few good points
yes Mysterio's powers do look a lot like
dr. Strange's powers not exact but
similar and it would be a really good
twist if he actually was learned in the
mystic arts but Mysterio is known for
being a liar an illusionist a trickster
perhaps he is lying about the multiverse
in fact I know many people who do think
he is lying I personally think that he
is in fact going to be the villain just
like in the comics and of course
spider-man will find out who he is and
we'll end up defeating him so that's it
for theory number four now on to the
final theory number five theory number
five comes from Anthony strauder and his
theory is about guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 Anthony thinks that Gamora and
Black Widow are trapped inside of the
soul stone and in Guardians vol 3 they
will come back they'll do this with the
help of Adam warlock who after some time
will be convinced that the guardians are
actually good in the comics Adam warlock
has a connection to the soul stone and
can even go in and out of soul world in
the movie Adam will go into the soul
world and communicate with Gamora and
Black Widow and ultimately will get them
out of it this theory does have some
presidents because Adam warlock is
supposed to be in guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 and his origin is deeply
connected to the soul stone it's
obviously changed a little bit in the
MCU but his character has always been
connected to the soul stone and in the
Infinity Gauntlet saga he was able to go
inside of the soul world and come out
this could be a way to get Gamora and
Black Widow out of the soul stone and
back into the universe as living people
if James Gunn decides to stick a little
bit to the comics we might in fact see
Soul world in guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 well that does it for this week's
theories let's do a quick recap theory
number one is that in spider-man far
from home there will actually be two
mysterious
one good and one bad theory number two
is that when Professor hullick snapped
he saw Natasha just like Fano saw Gamora
theory number three is that Quicksilver
is actually still alive and was revived
the same way they revived agent coulson
and agents of shield theory number four
is that mysterio is not from an
alternate universe but is in fact
learned in the mystic arts and
eventually spider-man will figure out
that he is actually a villain an theory
number five is that in guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 Adam warlock will go into
the soul world and get out Gamora and
Black Widow so those are this week's
theories do not forget to vote on which
one you think is your favorite and if
you would like to submit a theory of
your own for a chance to end up in an
episode of Theory Thursdays you can find
the email in the description down below
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
an episode and so you can say up to date
on everything relating to Marvel as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]